the
realm do you know what the realm
is it's the Thousand Blades of aon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a
lie what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another Game of Thrones
in House of the Dragon update video in
this video I will go over some of the
new information regarding House of the
Dragon second season there have been a
number of new updates about some of the
episodes as well as the official trailer
that was shown during HBO's recent event
in New York City now for those of you
who might not know HBO is no longer
filming House of the Dragon second
season they were able to finish filming
all their scenes a few weeks ago all of
their footage for the new season is now
in the hands of their editors as well as
whoever they hir to do their special
effects it will be a few more months
before everything is done and ready to
release on HBO and HBO Max now if you
saw my recent video video then you know
HBO showed a rough version of a trailer
during a media event in New York City
according to the media officials who
were there they say House of the Dragon
new trailer is an epic reemergence into
the world of Westerose not only that but
the sources who are close to Georgia are
Martin speculate that it might be
released in as little as a few days
while they have been a reliable source
before I find it hard to believe that
HBO would release that same trailer in
only a few days it is a rough version
after all we normally would not see a
full off official trailer until much
later if you're someone who followed
Game of Thrones then you know HBO likes
to release them with less than 90 days
before they air the first episode of a
new season if anything I do think we
could see a short teaser something that
might be less than 1 minute in length
then again I'm merely speculating as
well maybe these insiders are right
sources who know George Aram Martin
should certainly know more than me in
fact I hope they are right and we do see
it very soon that would obviously make
most of us very happy now I want to show
you some of the other new information
that was revealed this is in regards to
a few of House of the Dragons episodes
from the new season according to other
sources we will see Lord corus valyon
leave his home of driftmark and sail on
his ship in full battle armor during the
final episode of the upcoming season
many fans are already thinking this is
when the sea snake heads out into the
battle of the gallet also known as the
battle in the gallet it remains as one
of the most bloody a sea battles in all
of Westeros history thousands of men Di
during the battle and spice town was
never the same house valeron's
incredible Fleet lost nearly onethird of
its size however what might be worst of
all was when rira lost her Heir as well
as another Dragon ultimately the battle
was very costly for both sides and could
be considered a tactical victory for the
greens due to the death of rir a as well
as one of their commanders the greens
however had failed in their goal to
break the hold of the valyon fleet on
the east coast of Westeros more over the
greens allies in the southern free City
suffered such heavy losses that they no
longer stood by them for the remainder
of the dance of the Dragons
unfortunately we will not see this
battle in the second season because they
shortened it by a few episodes we will
have to wait until the third season in
order to finally see the battle and the
goet get brought to life in other news
sources also say the first Cena house of
the Dragon second season will be held in
Winterfell at the home of house Stark we
should have several scenes in Winterfell
this season considering rira's son
Jaker's valyon is on his way there as we
speak as you all know rira had her sons
leave Dragon Stone during the season 1
finale in order to find her some much
needed alliances unfortunately her son
Luc car's never made it out of Storm's
end alive Jay on the other hand is on
his way to the veil white Harbor and
then Winterfell although that very first
scene in the new season will be in
Winterfell I don't think Jace will be
there just yet he should be getting
familiar with the lady of house Aaron
while we're at Winterfell getting our
introduction to house Stark I know I'll
be very excited to finally see
Winterfell again after all these years I
hope it does look similar to what it did
in Game of Thrones I don't think
Winterfell should look very different
considering it's only about 170 years
before the events in the main show I
highly doubt they've had home and garden
over to do any Renovations lately but we
shall see now as I've said in other
videos we also know the name of the
first episode will be a son for a son a
reference to Damon and riro wanting to
get revenge for the death of her son Luc
car's valyon I'm sure all of you can use
your imagination to figure out what that
might mean if you don't already since
Renea already lost one of her sons she's
going to want Allison to suffer the same
fate in this first episode I'm guessing
we will see wif fell first as stated by
the sources we're going to get our
introduction to house Stark then I'm
sure we will see where jer's valyon is
at along his journey to find his
mother's allies we should also see the
Fallout of what happened during the end
of the first season season Damon and
rera will decide how they want to
respond to lary's early demise and I'll
also be very interested to see how Amon
reveals what happened to his mother and
Sado I'm hoping we get the exact same
scene word for word that was written by
George R Martin in Fire and Blood we
might even get our first scene of King
aegon sitting on the Iron Throne that
will make for an iconic image whether we
like seeing him sit there or not now
according to another source the fourth
episode of the new season will be named
a dance of dragons
once again I'm sure most of you can
imagine what that might mean obviously
we're about to see the blacks and the
greens unleash hell on one another the
show's creators are about to take things
to the next level when Ravens carried
the news of aun's Coronation to
Dragonstone princess reira summoned her
own black council with her was her uncle
and husband Damon Taren considered by
many to be the most dangerous man in
Westeros few Lords supported her but the
greatest of these was corus valan who
controlled the largest Fleet in the
realm and his targaryan wife Ry the old
King's sister then there were her five
Sons although none grown to manhood a
pitiful assembly really combined they
couldn't match the power of house high
tower alone but rira had
dragons she Damon and Ry rode huge and
formidable beasts and three of her five
Sons were Riders as well now before I go
I want to show you a fun little message
George R Martin shared earlier today on
his social media he uploaded this photo
as a way to mess with us fans who always
get on him about not releasing The Winds
of Winter I thought it was kind of funny
and I'm sure some of you will feel the
same way as always I will let you know
whenever I find out any new information
about the A Song of Ice and Fire novels
or HBO's Game of Thrones shows make sure
you subscribe if you want to be the
first ones to know whenever I release a
new video once again I have to thank all
of you for watching this one I hope you
all have a great day I will see see you
again very soon
[Music]
bye